[Music]
private Equity is all about buying
companies and selling them on ideally at
a profit
but with markets in turmoil and the
economy struggling more and more private
Equity groups are turning to a new
solution they're selling companies to
themselves
here's how it works private Equity
groups are under time pressure to sell
companies because they have to give
their investors their money back within
about 10 years let's say that decade is
coming to an end and the deal makers
running a private Equity Fund don't want
to sell a company maybe that company is
so great that they don't want to let go
or maybe its value has fallen or there
aren't many buyers around
so if you're a private Equity Group you
create some new fund which you control
and then you sell that company or even a
handful of companies from your old fund
into that new one
you use the proceeds of the sale to
repay the investors in the old fund
unless they want to roll over and become
investors in the new one
Clayton and debilier and rice sold
bellron a windscreen repair company to
itself in this way
General Atlantic did so with a group of
companies including Red Ventures the
media company behind the Lonely Planet
travel guides
but where does the money come from
often the new fund gets its money from a
group of investors known as second
refunds which ultimately get their cash
from the same kinds of Pension funds and
Sovereign wealth funds of the private
Equity groups themselves
sometimes they'll bring in other private
Equity groups or Sovereign wealth funds
too
in fact a lot of private Equity Funds
themselves run these secondaries
businesses including big names like
Blackstone Carlisle and CBC
which means private Equity firms are
providing the financing that enables
their rival private Equity firms to sell
their own companies to themselves
supporters say these deals give private
Equity groups more time and let them
hold on to good companies
but critics say it's a way for
billionaire deal makers to make more and
more money in fees
some stock market investors have warned
that it's not healthy to let companies
keep on being passed on privately at
higher and higher valuations perhaps the
main concern is even simpler
you can never really be sure who's
getting a good deal and who is losing
out
[Music]